herr lauterbach es ist heiko maas zu
zitieren mit einem satz den man sich
noch mal richtig verstehen muss im
august noch im august könnten die
einschränkungen fallen denn es gibt
rechtlich und politisch keine
rechtfertigung mehr für irgendeine
einschränkung er meint alle
einschränkungen und er meint bundesweit
fallen dann alle masken nein das wird
nicht stattfinden und ist auch rein
rechnerisch also weit von der realität
also wir das impf tempo das wir derzeit
noch haben also sind im tempo sehr stark
zurückgegangen übrigens einer der gründe
weshalb ich auch diese öffnung falsch
bin komme ich gleich noch mal zu aber es
ist ein post zurückgegangen daher sind
wir niemals in der lage schon mit der
august oder ende august auf eine
herdenimmunität zu kommen also die in
irgendeiner weise eine solche drastische
öffnung ist er quasi eine englisch
öffnung also eine boris johnson
ähnlicher also heiko maas also die ich
sehr schätze das schlägt ja hier eine
boris johnson ähnlicher öffnung noch im
august wenn jedem ein angebot gemacht
genau das ist ja auch sehr gebrauchen
gesagt aber das ist aber nicht möglich
wir werden nicht in der lage sein von
den impfstoff mengen die wir haben uns
auch selber wissen zu tun was ist zu tun
und es wird darüber hinaus auch noch so
sagen dass es in der bevölkerung gruppen
gibt die man schlecht impfen kann weil
die impfungen aus nicht gut wirkt oder
die gar nicht geimpft werden können und
man muss auch vorsichtig sein also was
bedeutet dieses angebot gemacht zu haben
also es bis mitte oder ende august geht
sowieso nicht lang aber das reicht ihre
rechnungslegung maß darauf haben sie
eine idee die kommt ja auf den gedanken
des zu machen stößt stößt einer
diskussion an und das ist immer gut
immer wichtig nur das ist ganz klar das
ist jetzt auch anlass für das gespräch
das wir hier haben aber ich halte das
ich halte es für unrealistisch und wir
haben die wir haben wieder den impfstoff
noch wäre es also zu rechtfertigen dann
die schleusen zu öffnen war das würde
bedeuten wenn man alles öffnet also wenn
man einfach alles öffnet und selbst wenn
alle an ebenfalls gebot gehabt hätten
viele haben es nicht wahrgenommen
dann hätten wir sehr hohe fallzahlen und
auch entsprechende medizinische
konsequenzen einschließlich longo wird
das aus meiner sicht
nicht zuende dekliniert gut zu nordrhein
westfalen kommen wir noch wir stellen
jetzt erstmal henrik strikt vor den wir
auch logischerweise kennen weil auch
einen gern gesehen dass diese sendung
virologe uni bonn expertenrat
nordrhein-westfalen großbritannien
großbritannien steigen die inzidenz
zahlen boris johnson ist zitiert mit
diesen 50.000 infektionen sein
gesundheitsminister sagt sogar es
könnten auch hunderttausend werden und
dennoch öffnet er zum 19
das land ist der mutig oder ist der bug
halte ich das finde ich sehr schwer zu
sagen einmal etwas über andere länder
wenn man selber nicht da ist heute kam
zum beispiel berichte vom von national
statistics ob die eben auch die korona
daten sammelt die suggerieren dass 90
prozent der erwachsenen briten einen
antikörper gegen korona haben das ist
eine enorm hohe zahl also die
erwachsenen ja 99 in england das ist
natürlich ein ein wert von dem man nur
mit impfen und wirklich auch infektionen
erreicht trotz allem sieht man eben
einen deutlichen anstieg der
infektionszahlen auf ziemlich hohem
level das bestimmt auch mit der delta
variante zu tun hat und also ich kann
jetzt nicht sagen ich finde das was ich
aber ich kann auch nicht sagen dass ich
das so mit lockerem auge sehe sie auch
sagen in delta liegt eine gefahr das ist
ja jetzt auszusprechen also 40 prozent
wenigstens ansteckender als die alpha
variante ich sage darin liegt ich sage
nicht darin liegt eine gefahr weil wir
sehen eine deutlichere übertragung aber
das virus ist auch schon dominant bei
uns und ist es eben etwas gewinnt wer
jetzt umgehen müssen die maßnahmen die
wir ergreifen wirken genauso gut gegen
die delta variante die wir kennen mit
dem test genauso gut die delta variante
und die impfstoffe vor allem der
zweifache impfstoff wirkt genauso gut
gegen die delta variante das sind
wichtige faktoren und daher jetzt zu
sagen diese variante schlimmer oder die
wird noch schlimmer werden ich finde das
ist nicht sehr pragmatisch
gegangen sondern wir wissen die
maßnahmen wirken in nrw wird ausprobiert
ob man öffnen kann durch wirklich
strikte maßnahmen durch ein konstantes
testen wenn es nicht funktioniert wird
ja an sehr schnell schon wieder die
reißleine gezogen und wieder geschlossen
dass das sind für mich gute
vorgehensweise wäre wir müssen wir
ausprobieren welche hygienemaßnahmen
funktionieren wir müssen schauen wie wir
uns vorsichtig an einer achtsamen
normalität ran und die bei data nur noch
mal um nachzufragen der gibt gab es aus
israel das ist angeklungen meldungen
darüber dass der wirkstoff dass der
impfstoff nicht ganz so erfolgreich
wirkt gegen diese ansteckende delta
variante da ist natürlich auch die frage
welches risiko trägt dann der einzelne
wenn er eben mit delta dennoch sich
infizieren kann und vielleicht eben auch
wieder krank werden kann
also man muss erst mal sagen die
impfstoffe wurden entwickelt um vor
einem schweren verlauf zu schützen und
das schaffen sie das schaffen sie
genauso gut auch bei der delta variante
zusätzlich haben wir den effekt dass er
auch eine immunität bringt also eine
sterile immunität dass das virus nicht
mehr leicht weitergegeben werden da
spielen viele verschiedene faktoren
mittelrhein und man kann jetzt nicht
einfach sagen
der impfschutz dieser sterilen immunität
ist nach unten gedrückt weil zb wenn wir
uns erinnern ganz am anfang von krone
haben wir darüber geredet ob die
influenza-impfung nicht auch gegen
korona wirken kann
weil so eine immun aktivierungen im
körper gibt die bei solchen stoffen
enorm starkes mini alle wissen sei ganz
am anfang ich ein produkt also aber dass
die sofern hatte ja auf den punkt
hingewiesen
die studie die daten aus israel vom
gesundheitsministerium dort die haben ja
gezeigt dass der schutz vor also
schwerem verlauf und 93% beträgt das ist
eigentlich ein bisschen eine
enttäuschung gewesen also so ein
schlechter schutz bis hinten ist bis
dahin aufwendig studie sich bestätigt
dass es ja ganz klar was wäre eine
wichtige information bisher war es immer
so dass der schutz vor schweren verlauf
zu 99 prozent gewährleisten und aber
nicht
stimmt aber nicht die studien waren
vorher zwischen 94 und 96 prozent
vorsehen tomaten verlauf der schwere
verlauf also tot und sehr schwerer
verlauf oder war der schutz höher
nein der schutz vor schweren verlauf war
auch in dieser schon frau bern kann sich
bestimmt nicht einmal übernehmen darf
kann sich bestimmt auch gut für dich
studien erinnern ja das ist eine sehr
schöne überleitung die jetzt mal dann
auch gleich nehme und sage wir begrüßen
in münchen die wissenschaftsredakteurin
der süddeutschen zeitung christine bernd
gombert können sie uns helfen bei der
frage wie gefährlich ist tatsächlich
dieses delta virus und wie wirksam sind
die impfstoffe die wir haben also es
bleibt schon in der summe so dass die
doppelte impfung sehr gut gegen delta
gegen die schweren verläufe und den tod
schützt aber tatsächlich zeigen die
daten aus israel
es ist etwas weniger gut als gegen die
alpha variante und frühere varianten
also es gibt da so einen leichten
verlust aber das sind letztlich prozente
also ob jetzt 98 oder 96 solche studien
haben ja auch immer eine gewisse
unsicherheit nun also es gibt erste
hinweise dass es vielleicht nicht ganz
so gut ist vor allem wissen wir aber die
erste impfung hilft noch nicht sehr gut
und wir wissen auch die infektionen
kommen leichter zum tragen also es gibt
vielmehr durchbruch infektionen viel
mehr infizierte mit dieser variante das
ist eigentlich die wichtigste message
und zu der battle hier zwischen herrn
lauterbach und herrn strick in bezug auf
die schwerst erkrankungen und die
todesfälle
da lag das zwischen 96 und 94 oder bei
99 bei 98 aus meiner sicht aber wie
gesagt zuhause und eine leichte
schwächung und das sind eben
verschiedene studien die verschiedene
zahlen zeigen von daher ich würde mich
da nicht um diese einzelnen
prozentpunkte streiten wenn jetzt sagen
wir das super 98 prozent wäre ich habe
also einige studien gesehen was 99 aber
bleiben wir einfach bei 98 und bei der
israelischen studie da kam jetzt raus
ist sind also
sozusagen 96 oder ist 95 an sind weniger
menschen vorjahr das sind das sind zwei
zweieinhalb mal so viele leute dich
schwer erkranken also ich muss das jetzt
in der einen kurorte 1000 erkranken dass
sie eine sehr kurze zwangspause das
finde ich ein großer unternehmer sollten
sich nicht ignorieren und trotzdem muss
man sagen das ist bisher eine studie aus
israel dass johanna tieren selbst die
rutsche gelegen ja sozusagen die kann
man jetzt noch nicht eins zu eins
übertragen also vielleicht können wir so
mal ganz kurz dazu kommen in aller
schönheit im wahrsten sinne des wortes
der geschätzte kollegin zu begrüßen
einer schneider nämlich journalistin
chefreporterin von der welt schneider
wir haben das hier in deutschland ja
alles wirklich immer sehr sehr ernst
genommen und sehr auf sicherheit gesetzt
sie haben sogar menschen noch in
quarantäne für zwei wochen geschickt die
schon doppelt geimpft waren wir dachten
und achteten immer sehr auf abstand und
masken tragen
geht ihnen das jetzt mit den öffnungen
über die wir denken mit diesen zitaten
von politikern ein bisschen zu schnell
dass wir jetzt im sommer plötzlich in
diese situation ja irgendwie aufmachen
ich finde es überhaupt nicht zu schnell
und dann laden die situation sieht man
wir rechnen in zahlen die eigentlich so
hoch sind dass man sich fragen muss
welches risiko der einzelnen noch bereit
selbst zu tragen oder werden jetzt
eineinhalb jahre pandemie hinter uns und
die das werte verhältnis hat sich so
stark in richtung sicherheit und weg von
freiheit verschoben dass man auf die
idee kommt für den rest müsste auch der
einzelne verantwortlich sein und ich
spreche jetzt auch weil sie erwähnt
haben die die im sport dann müsste das
mit dass sein würden erreichen werden
ich bin trotzdem der meinung dass ein
impfangebot wenn das gegeben ist
jedermann das abbilden kann will kann es
ablehnen muss ablehnen können aber es
ist nicht die aufgabe des staates den
einzelnen gegen seinen willen zu
schützen
also nach ihrer meinung müsste noch
immer 100 prozent haben in einer studie
oder aber das 7 prozent das ist ganz
schlimm aber dass die erste studie des
israel muss man schauen was entwickelt
aber nach wie vor gibt und das hat herr
strecke auch hat gemeint dass die
doppelte impfung sehr gut hilft dass die
neue variante also ich finde die
diskussion die
jetzt in diesem sinne heraus angestoßen
hat eigentlich sogar gut er hat
eigentlich auch nur wiederholt was
eigentlich schon lange am kaffeestand
nämlich sobald jeder impfangebot
bekommen hat vor allem die rechtlichen
bedingungen weg andere innere freiheit
einzuschränken und es eigentlich
wahnsinn oder wahnsinn ich finde es
irritierend wenn dann jens spahn kommt
und das eigentlich gleich passiert und
sagt wir sind quasi das verwirrte nur
die menschen und werden noch sehr lange
mit allen maßnahmen leben müssen finden
die schwierig weil eigentlich wenn man
geimpft ist so dass fünf lassen kann
muss doch irgendwie ein spielraum da
sein weil sonst immer wirklich im never
ending und dann ist trotzdem ja die
frage es gibt ein risiko für den
einzelnen frau berndt ist gleich daran
es gibt ein risiko für den einzelnen
aber es gibt natürlich auch das risiko
für andere und auch das vorbild von
politik also wir haben gerade herr
aiwanger zitiert wenn jetzt der
stellvertretende ministerpräsident von
bayern für sich festlegt ich will mich
nicht impfen lassen ist das ist das
reine privatsache mal so gefragt ich
finde ich absolut also vor allem was
wäre das für ein verlangen von einem
politiker in seinem privaten bereich
einzugreifen und muss das wirklich
machen uns repräsentieren
ich finde werden er der bevölkerung zur
verfügung stellt dass sich jeder impfen
lassen kann
er ist kein corona leuten oder ähnliches
die politik durch ist öffnung als
schließung
aber das ist eine private entscheidung
also dass in so einer welt die echten
leben in der politiker sich gegen den
willen etwas körperliches antun müssen
dass sie nicht wollen und seine es ist
absolut entscheidung ich finde das ist
höchst persönliche lebensbereich gehen
die öffnungen in nordrhein westfalen zu
weit wollten wir nicht vergessen zu
fragen frau band was sagen sie wie groß
ist das risiko ist das klug was die
nordrhein westfälische regierung jetzt
entschieden hat ich finde es vollkommen
unklug und ich wundere mich auch ich
habe so ein bisschen die ravidass
erinnert mich alles an anfang märz als
auch nordrhein-westfalen vorprescht und
sagte jetzt öffnen wir und damals hatten
wir die alpha variante die kam und jeder
wusste das bringt jetzt neuen schwung
das bringt die dritte welle da gingen
die zahlen auch schon hoch trotzdem hat
man geöffnet um dann sehr bald diese
öffnung wieder zurückzunehmen und so
kommt es mir jetzt auch wieder vor wir
öffnen obwohl wir wissen dass wir gerade
wirklich wieder neuen winter
in dieser pandemie mit dieser delta
variante man muss ja eben nur ins
ausland blicken um zu sehen was da
passiert also ich stimme frau schneider
zu irgendwann muss man öffnen und muss
man diese pandemie auch für beendet
erklären wenn und dass man auch beim
irgendwann leuten wieder sagt okay ihr
habt die chance auf eine impfung wenn
ihr sie nicht ergreift dann ist das in
ordnung dann öffnen wir halt und lassen
maßnahmen fallen aber diesen punkt haben
wir ja jetzt noch nie im moment wäre es
ist es aus meiner sicht hochgradig
unfair zu öffnen
all jenen gegenüber die eben noch keine
schutzimpfung haben und die bislang auch
gar keinen zugang haben also wir sind ja
weit weg von einem doppelten impfangebot
plus 14 tage für alle menschen in dieser
republik sagte bernd schneider geben
schon den finger
ich würde sagen wir brauchen diese
juristische dass wir seit eineinhalb
jahren auf die inzidenz zahlen starren
und ich glaube dass inzwischen auch sehr
viele einig dass das nicht einfach der
einzige indikator sein kann
und auch da beim ins ausland blickt
steigen trotzdem die dosierungen oder
intensiv bewegung nicht im selben
ausmass und auch die todeszahlen nicht
also insofern verstehe ich total dass
nordrhein westfalen jetzt öffnet weil
noch mal der fokus allein auf den
tendenzen jetzt gar nicht so viel
aussagt wie ihr vielleicht mann
ausgesagt habt so wir sind bei verband
noch mal bei einem interessanten
kollegen der sich heute zu wort gemeldet
hat der chef aller intensivmediziner
nämlich professor gerne und magst der
sagt dass diese vierte welle wenn sie
denn käme überhaupt nie zu vergleichen
wäre mit denen zuvor eben weil wir schon
einen erklecklichen teil der menschen
geimpft haben und auch zweit geimpft
haben
das ist der chef der intensivmediziner
des landes denkt er sich dass aus der
sich auch nein wir haben natürlich eine
gewisse schutzwirkung auch schon jetzt
durch diesen dieser impfquote die wir
jetzt haben gar keine frage ja also von
daher man sieht es ist ein stück weit
entkoppelt von den intensiv belegungen
von den todeszahlen jahr in england gar
keine frage gleichwohl stehen wir
letztlich am beginn einer vierten welle
und wie groß die wir hängt natürlich vor
allem davon ab wie jetzt unsere
impfquote unser impfen voran
schreitet je früher diese welle kommt
desto schlimmer wird sie werden dann
werden wir vielleicht auch wieder ins
tänzen von 400 erreichen und insofern
wäre es so klug wir würden einfach noch
ein bisschen vorsichtig sein und es
soweit hinauszögern bis genügend
menschen geimpft sind
herr lauterbach ist doch nicht trennen
sondern der leinwand ist dran
herr laumann sind sieben waghalsig
gleiche frage wir sind nicht weiter als
ich weil wir zum beispiel überall da wo
menschen hingehen müssen die maske zwang
lassen
sie können in nordrhein westfalen nicht
in ein kaufhaus gehen ohne maske sie
können die straßenbahn fahren ohne maske
sie können in einer arztpraxis gehen
ohne maske also das haben wir ja alles
gelassen
ich sage auch auf der anderen seite
werden die ministerpräsidenten und die
bundesregierung gemeinsam entscheiden
dass demnächst wieder fußball spiele in
ganz deutschland egal in welchem
bundesland mit 25.000 leute möglich sind
wenn ich mehr als 50 prozent an die
steigungs besetzt sind dann finde ich
dann ist die dorfkirmes immerhin
heimatdorf auch eine sache gehen und wir
haben ganz teilweise nur darauf legt
großen wert und das darf man in der
debatte nicht vergessen es gibt kein
bundesland was so streng testet wie
nordrhein westfalen
wir haben selbst zurzeit am tag noch
über 300.000 proteste die tester von in
den betrieben zählen sicher nicht und
sie wisse dass sie der arbeitgeber zwei
teste in der woche seinen mitarbeitern
veröffentlichen zur verfügung stellen
muss ich gehe da sie zurzeit nicht in
der schule gut tester haben wenig und
vergessene bitte auch nicht setzen sie
das mal durch das jeder der aus dem
urlaub zurückkommt jetzt in nordrhein
westfalen wenn er den ersten tag wieder
arbeiten geht wenn er mehr als fünf tage
urlaub hat muss an negativen test
vorzeichen
damit kriegen wir doch eine testung von
14.15 video as rom 12 13 millionen leute
in nordrhein westfalen in den nächsten
sechs wochen hin wo in welchem
bundesland gibt es das und wir finden
zurzeit in dem bürger testung und bei
den 300.000 diebe so ungefähr am tag
haben ja noch 0,06 prozent positive aber
wir haben bei allen bürger testungen bis
heute in nordrhein-westfalen seitdem
dies gibt 100.000 leute gefunden
und ich behaupte dass die fast alle wo
sie zum büro test gegangen sind nicht
geglaubt haben dass sie infiziert sind
und ich glaube werden jetzt jetzt in
einer disco die leute treffen am
wochenende in einer kommune die unter 10
ist und alle in der disco sind getestet
er ist das glaube ich genauso
verantwortbar als wären sie bei schönen
wetter samstagabend sich in den
kneipenvierteln unserer innenstädte
genauso bewegen ob das in köln ist ob
das in düsseldorf ist ob das in münster
ist das ist einfach realität als jetzt
corona nie gegeben und dann haben wir
mit den impfstoffen hier aber eine
besondere situation
astrazeneca lesen wir ist dank der
entscheidung empfehlung der stiko im
grunde tod oder sehen sie das anders die
ärzte aus nordrhein westfalen sagen sie
bestellen es nicht mehr das sind nicht
nur ärzte aus nordrhein westfalen aber
astra ist im grunde genommen tod ja das
ist schade aber ich zurzeit ist es so
die wissenschaftler sagen ja dass wenn
man einmal wird astral geimpft ist wie
ich zum beispiel und lässt sich jetzt
das zweite mal mit marion tag empfunden
dass das eine gute mischung ist und zu
einem guten aber dieser impfstoff kommt
jetzt in die grabbelkiste und ja
verschenkt das ist wahnsinnig großzügig
aber er fehlt natürlich in der eigenen
kampagne oder werbung also also zurzeit
in ordnung ist also ich habe fast eine
millionen dosen astra zenica weil wir
letzte woche eine grosse liga bekommen
haben ich habe unsere leute sagen
schreib bitte genau aus wie lange sich
das das impfmittel hält weil ist nicht
vor meinem gewissen verantworten kann
das nur kommt denn ich denke auch an
anderen notfalls eine andere länder die
vielleicht froh wären wenn sie den
impfstoff hätten
ich will nur eins sagen zurzeit haben
wir so viel moderner und bei jenen tag
im stoff dass wir das mit dem zweite
impfung und lockern hinkriegen und sie
müssen in nordrhein westfalen ein see
wir haben über die ostertage und die
woche nach ostern in nordrhein-westfalen
460.000 menschen mit astrazeneca hilft
weil wir damals diese aktion gemacht
haben da haben jetzt die zweite
impfungen angestanden
ein großer teil ist noch zweimal mit
astra zion ehre empfunden
aber diese woche haben wir nur bei antec
gemacht
und das möchte ich auch noch einmal zu
den impftermin absagen und sagen wir
haben elf zentren da fehlen uns von der
aktion ostern geimpft dann haben wir
gesagt ihr werdet zwölf wochen später
kriegt in die zweite impfung war das
damals die meinung war schieben die
zweite ebenso heraus wie es geht damit
wir viel erstimpfung machen können dass
davon ein teil vielleicht nichts fünf
wochen warten wollte wenn man mal die
debatte bei astrazeneca sieht wie
schnell man sich impfen lassen soll die
seit ostern gegeben hat dass der ein
oder andere dann auch zum hausarzt
gegangen und hat sich seine zweite
impfung geholt das ist das verstehe ich
gut
es wird ein schöner werde den terminen
im zentrum absagen würden aber ich kann
es verstehen und jetzt sage ich mal
deswegen glaube ich die menschen die
eine erste impfung haben in aller regel
auch die zweite impfung sehr ernst
nehmen so jetzt haben wir den punkt von
den lagern und müssen aufpassen dass wir
nicht den faden verlieren
herr lauterbach wir sind exakt bei der
frage wie stellen wir überhaupt jetzt
noch einen impfschutz und eine
herdenimmunität her die bei 85 oder 90
prozent liegen müsste
schaffen wir das überhaupt schaffen wir
das unter diesen bedingungen und wie
überzeugt man leute auch diese zweite
impfung super toll zu finden also zum
einen ist für die gesamte impfkampagne
in nrw und ich bin ja selbst ebenfalls
in leverkusen
er ist die lage jetzt nicht einfacher
geworden jetzt wo alles gelockert wird
das signal was jetzt an die jungen leute
gesendet wird
die party ist vorbei und es ist ich
nicht und das ist sie nicht und daher
werden werden viele jungen otto die
werden einfach sagen okay das ist jetzt
vorbei ist schon überall gelockert es
geht schon wieder in die disco über kann
man in dieser marke sind auf kann
losgehen aber über teslas ja aber das
wird ja übrigens auch nur sporadisch
prüfen nur wenn man wenn das umrechnet
300.000 es das sind 1,5 prozent der
leute die getestet werden das nicht
dramatisch also somit das wird schwerer
werden das falsche signal das stimmig
frau berndt zu das falsche signal ist
gegeben worden die pandemie ist vorbei
jetzt ist es so jetzt das normale leben
beginnt wieder
und diejenigen die es gibt viele die
sind quasi im prinzip im fällig wir
haben aber die mühe gescheut sich ins
ins zentrum zu begeben und die haben zum
teil keinen hausarzt auf die müssen wir
zu gehen wenn man das noch retten will
dann müssen wir den impfstoff dorthin
bringen wo wir diese leute treffen an
die shisha bar es beispielsweise in die
ausgeben heilen beispielsweise in an die
kölner ringe im hamburger
schanzenviertel in berlin in den
friedrichshain wo die jungen leute sind
dann muss es möglich sein dass die sich
impfen lassen können mit mobilen ins
teams ohne jeden aufwand dann kommt man
noch einen schritt weiter
aber ich glaube dass wir jetzt wirklich
in eine phase hinein kommen wo wir für
die impfung kämpfen wollen und nicht in
den modernen stoff aber endlich da ist
ja der große forint und der inder im
stoff den man will in dem sinne und ich
stimme ihnen nicht so also wenn es uns
nicht gelingt die jungen leute zu
erreichen oder zu sind ja nicht nur
junge leute sondern sind auch er sich
nicht haben ebenfalls ein bisschen wenn
es uns nie als politiker nicht gelingt
die diese leute zu erreichen
man kann ich sagen okay die sind jetzt
jetzt schuld wenn ich will da hat schon
wenn die wenn dann die die data variante
durch schläfe und werden mal wegen sehr
viele schwere fälle in den kliniken
dann kann ich nicht sagen na ja die
leute hätten sich noch impfen lassen
können und er legt zusammen etwa oder
kriegt keine luft mehr oder da ist uns
einander gestorben
die hätten sich noch impfen lassen
können das kann nicht unsere haltung
seien interessante fall gehen wir sofort
weiterhin frau schneider weil das ist ja
genau die frage bis wohin reicht
eigentlich die verantwortung des staates
und in anführungszeichen welches risiko
welches restrisiko hat der einzelne zu
tragen und damit ihr aber auch die
gesellschaft weil sie gegebenenfalls
behandlungskosten tragen muss da die
lehrer mittendrin
also ich bin überhaupt der in derselben
meinung dass politiker in erster linie
dafür verantwortlich sind dass die
kampagne läuft das war aber das hat ja
schon hat mit gestartet jetzt ins laufen
kommen und jetzt die ganze sache poppen
die ganze meldungen auf dass man sich
jetzt bemüht ebenso mobile teams zu
schaffen genau die ihre alle vorschläge
unternehmen einer woche passiert es
nicht schon längst das passiert schon
ordnet daten die weiß aber in österreich
zum beispiel läuft es schon seit jahren
vielleicht mehr als einer woche drin ich
hatte letzte woche da finde ich mal
impfstoff und dass man zu sagen ich habe
den impfstoff jetzt erst seit 45 daten
dafür um überhaupt so etwas in großem
umfang machen ja also dass die impf
busse
ist jung wie auch mit anderen also mit
kanada und amerika verglichen worden
da kann man das irgendwie an der
tankstelle machen und einem supermarkt
aber sind jeder zu kompliziert sie mir
auf jeden fall immer nicht in österreich
drin und ich finde die deutsche
bürokratie trotzdem atemberaubend und
das sagt sehr viel aus also ja und
deswegen finde ich auch diese diskussion
das ist für mich das absolut ab so dass
der blutdruck zu sprechen ob man ihn
schwenzer bestraft weil eben weiß nicht
warum jemand dieser impfung nicht
erschienen ist natürlich ist es nicht in
ordnung und in teilen sich auch sozial
wenn es jemand absichtlich macht aber
man kennt die gründe nicht in diskussion
die so deutsch ist finden weil das gibt
es in österreich und in der schweiz halt
schon gar nicht also es ist eine ganz
ganz eigenartige herangehensweise an den
bürger also nur gibt also seit wann
kontrolliert der staat den bürger und
nicht nur der bürger den staaten gemacht
dass ganz unrecht trägt soll man im
schwenzer bestrafen also auch ein
krankengymnastik kurs den man irgendwie
schleift muss man am ende bezahlen
winfried kretschmann hat gefordert
lauterbach glaube ich auch dass leute
die sowas verschlimmern irgendwie
wenigstens dafür zahlen
nein also ich finde strafen so was mit
strafen zu beantworten ist einfach zu
setzen einmal vollkommen falschen anreiz
wir müssen dürfen nicht vergessen dass
vor allem jetzt berufstätige geimpft
werden da kommt vielleicht ein termin am
nächsten tag rein und man will sich
nicht krank fühlen an dem tag und
verschiebt den termin das muss
eigentlich anders herum laufen das
angebot für das impfen muss so
niedrigschwellig sein dass man auch eben
kurzfristig entscheiden kann man möchte
immer gehen und dazu kommt eben dann
auch noch dass man den einfach eine
bessere aufklärung machen muss es heißt
nicht nur ärmel hoch und damit hat sich
das man muss aufklären was der impfstoff
ist worauf der ausgebaut aufgebaut ist
und dass er mit dem körper macht damit
die leute auch ihre skepsis darüber über
weil überwinden aber mit mit strafen
drohen damit es nicht die kleidung ich
würde mal sagen wir haben termin
buchungssysteme gehabt die nicht mal
zuließen dass man termine verändern
konnte er das also wir haben ja sind
also eher wie wir können jetzt bei uns
als zwei wochen in beiden landesteilen
vorher ging es gar nicht überall und es
würde ich kann doch nicht die leute
bestrafen wenn man sich nur
der kompliziert oder fast gar nicht
abmelden konnte man muss ja auch einfach
mal sehen was da für eine technik hinter
stand und das sehen sie zu sprüche was
soll das bestrafen die sind schnell
gemacht
man muss immer auf der anderen seite
gucken wie ist er wirklich die situation
der leutek behauptet viele ältere leute
haben doch nun impftermine bekommt war
die enkelkinder die termine gemacht
haben
in diesem buch und systemen wie wir das
letzten endes gemacht haben und da bin
ich sehr sehr vorsichtig ich sehe nur
wir haben viele niederschwellige
geschichten das ist niederschwellig ist
was wir haben sind die vielen
niedergelassenen hausärzte in unseren
bundesländern die das auch gerne und
sehr fleißig mal haben die der sehr
gerne machen die das ja fleißig mache
und ich sag ihnen auch ich habe heute
noch mit 1 ein landarzt gesprochen
der fühlt sich verantwortlich dass er
sein dorf impft und was besseres kann
uns gar nicht passiert wie das der
darauf achtet und sagt wir waren da noch
nicht wir waren da noch nicht warum ist
der noch nicht gekommen und ich glaube
schon dass wir eine gute impfquote in
den nächsten wochen bei uns in
deutschland erreichen werden ob ein hund
jetzt die 85 prozent erreichen aber bei
den über 60 jährigen haben wir sie schon
und weil den jüngeren da soll war auch
mal ein bisschen vor sich haben die
werden sich jetzt nicht mehr infrage wie
in der disco dürfen ich wollte noch mal
sagen viele junge konnten bislang gar
keinen impftermin buch weil wir eben
gesagt haben wir müssen erst die alten
fußball-lehrer im plus war die
erzieherin nicht alle rasers medizin
besprochen
genau also wir sind genau wie junge
leute da man bis zu den schutz nehme die
sind ja lama gedanke ist angekommen
die sind auch nicht um wir gehen nach
münchen zu frau band ist das nicht
tatsächlich die wahrheit verband dass
wir schon wieder anfangen menschen den
vorwurf zu machen die bis jetzt erstmal
entweder in diesem digitalen systemen
des buchens gescheitert sind oder die
überhaupt bisher keine möglichkeit
hatten die berühmte kostenlos studie
weist ja aus dass von den 50 von denen
die sich noch nicht haben impfen lassen
50% sich auf jeden fall impfen lassen
wollen genau also der wunsch der
menschen ist ja nach wie vor groß sich
impfen zu lassen es gibt sicher
verschiedene gründe weshalb diese
termine nicht wahrgenommen wurden
aber wichtig ist auch aus meiner sicht
ist einfach beim locken zu belassen und
nicht beim bestrafen
noch mal klar zu machen wie wichtig
diese impfung ist für den einzelnen
welchen großartigen schutz sie bietet
das sie der weg ist in unsere freiheit
die wir uns alle wünschen und den
menschen eben dieser aufklärung zukommen
lassen und dann vor allem bitte in die
gruppen gehen wo dieser
aufklärungsbedarf noch sehr hoch ist wir
wissen dass es nach wie vor so eine
soziale schere gibt und das ist sehr
sehr wichtig ist eben diese menschen in
den beengten wohnverhältnissen mit den
schwierigen berufen die in dieser
pandemie auch hinten runtergefallen sind
dass man die versorgt und ihnen die
möglichkeit ganz leicht gibt sich impfen
zu lassen so und damit sind wir noch mal
beim stichwort herdenimmunität und der
frage ob wir sie erreichen indem wir
herr lauterbach tatsächlich eben in
diese sozialen bis jetzt eben noch nicht
bedachten oder eben verunmöglichten
branchen- hineingehen und bereiche
hineingehen
oder müssen wir die kinder und
jugendlichen mit einbeziehen und
beziehen wir sie mit ein weil wir eben
eine herdenimmunität erreichen wollen
also man muss die bei anfragen
voneinander trennen
zunächst einmal ich persönlich bin was
die impfungen in den problembereichen
angeht etwas skeptischer als kollege
laumann war zum beispiel auch unsere in
fraktionen in mannes wegen die also
stadtteil impfungen
damit erreicht man ich hatte diesmal
ausgerechnet ich hatte also an eine
aktion noch selbst auto tage genommen
damit erreicht man vielleicht fünf
prozent der menschen die dort leben und
das ist schön das ist wichtig in dem
sinne aber da komme ich nirgendwo also
auf die quoten nicht benötigen würde um
nachher herdenimmunität darzustellen von
85 prozent
und das hat muss ungefähr unser ziel
sein wenn nicht sogar höher um die in
der data variante zu trotzen und sie
können auch also nicht sicher sein dass
dieser variante die letzte variante
überhaupt ist also es kann noch eine
gefährliche variante kommt hat zwei oder
drei also anläufe das virus es kann sein
dass wir also noch hören
somit also wir müssen aus meiner sicht
viel mehr machen um in die
problembereiche rein zu kommen und ein
paar hat vorstellbar ist schon gesagt
und jetzt dran trotzdem zu den kessel
realisieren muss im grunde menschen die
bis uns und weil da noch nicht die
chancen oder genau und zwar sehr kreativ
sehr kreativ also unbürokratisch kreativ
da muss auch wirklich und da spreche ich
die idee dass die leute die die impfung
nicht nehmen weil die aufklärung nicht
komplett gewesen weil die nicht genau
kapieren wie messenger rna eben stoff
funktioniert das ist abwegig sondern
diese leute die also sind zum teil mit
sophie und anderen problemen unterwegs
die würden dann eben stoff nehmen wenn
er quasi zu ihnen zu und käme und nicht
zu wissen was übersetzt und wir gehen
dann also bei den kindern ist meine
position nordisk eine politische
position sondern als wissenschaftler
nach der sicht also der studien also zu
longo witt bei kindern
die gute nachricht ist zunächst einmal
und bei kindern kann ich jetzt hier 12
bis 16 jahren
die gute nachricht bis 16 jährigen
kindern ist die dass gott sei dank sich
die ursprünglichen befürchtungen dass
kinder da sehr schwer erkranken oder ins
krankenhaus müssen
das sind eher selten sich auch schon
gesagt das war eine schottin dort
genauer gesagt der schottisch
vize-gesundheitsminister hatte sich
korrigiert und das habe ich dann
angenommen wenn sich eine also sagen wir
lage nachher besser darstellt als
ursprünglich gedacht bin ich immer froh
und träume das sehr gerne ein
aber was ich leider nicht verändert hat
ist das hier und da habe ich heute noch
mal studien gelesen und auch auf twitter
kommentiert also lasst nicht verändert
hat ist die relativ also sein mal
besorgniserregende situation auch bei
kindern bei lankowitz nach drei monaten
haben die kinder die erkrankt gewesen
sind in zu einem prozentsatz irgendwo
zwischen zwei und sieben prozent haben
die also symptome die nicht gut sind an
konzentrationsschwierigkeiten wir haben
zum teil also wortfindungsstörungen wir
haben zum teil also ernst werden ist ihr
argument weisenau man muss den kindern
anbieten also
und immer dahinter sondern ganz was ich
selber erkranken wir uns nicht nur wegen
der genauen nicht für die
herdenimmunität nicht zum schutz
erwarten was wenn wir das nicht machen
dann werden wir in den schulen im herbst
eine massive durchseuchung mit der delta
variante sehen dann in wir im prinzip
die kinder durch durch solche und wie es
im prinzip die impfung sicherer als die
impfung pernice deutscher die runde
machen weil es wahnsinnig viele menschen
verunsichert vorschneider die stiko die
ständige impfkommission sagt so eine
impfung ist für die kinder kein lakritz
bonbon auf der anderen seite wird eben
vor der erkrankung gewarnt und gesagt
wie viel von herrn lauterbach das sehr
infektion mit delta gefährlicher ist für
die kinder ist die impfung selbst was
sollen eltern machen
auch das liegt natürlich in ein
scheidender eltern beziehungsweise auch
in der der kinder ich fand da auch am
wieder jens spahn äußerung immerhin
sparen oder vor ein paar tagen oder war
gestern erst also nein denn die kinder
sollen selbst entscheiden also er wirft
auch mit vorschlägen um sich die
überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen kann
also ich bin nicht immer großer fan der
sticker und als einiges schiefgelaufen
eine kommunikation mit astrazeneca und
wie auch immer wissen wir alle aber
jetzt diese entscheidung nicht getroffen
zu haben finden die nicht schlimm wenn
sie es auf wissenschaftlicher basis
stellen wollen also ist doch in ordnung
wenn man irgendwie im kinder erst im
kreis das hat mehr nutzen als schaden
ich verstehe die einwände dass es im
herbst ein ganz großes problem werden
wird aber dann würde man halt von der
politik erwarten dass man sich auf beide
szenarien vorbereitet entweder ist es
tico entscheidet noch vor oktober oder
september oder wann auch immer jetzt
genau wo die schule losgeht dass die
geimpft werden können und muss dann eben
die impfstoffe haben damit schnell geht
oder man muss schauen dass der
unterricht trotzdem stattfinden kann
weil er wird schon das gefühl gelaufen
in cyber messer wie letztes jahr und es
wird ein fachwechsel durch geben wie
auch herr spanier schon angekündigt hat
eigentlich da muss man sich anders
aufstellen also man kann nicht darauf
warten dass die stiko innerhalb von der
nächsten zwei wochen die entscheidung
trifft da muss man schauen dass kinder
trotzdem die schule gehen können oder
also die lehrer geimpft sein oder
endlich gottes willen luftfilter
maschinen kaufen es kann ja echt nicht
so ein problem sondern eineinhalb jahren
pandemie für basic zu sorgen oder das
verstehe nicht ganz wir bleiben noch war
interessant mehr
interessante gedanken herr stricken kann
er da in den usa in anderen ländern
werden die jugendlichen kinder und
jugendlichen ab zwölf geimpft
er ist klug was die stiko macht zu sagen
schön ruhig kein lakritz bonbon müssen
erst abwarten
oder denken sie es ist klug die kinder
und jugendlichen einzubeziehen
nun erstmal muss ich sagen ich finde die
stiko arbeitet sehr transparent wie sie
ihre arbeit und kommuniziert das auch
richtig also wenn man die mechanismen
der stiko versteht das sind eben viele
experten die sich da wirklich den kopf
darüber zerbrechen wie man da mit den
daten umgeht und da wird eben auch sehr
viel diskutiert und das ist die
derzeitige entscheidung der stiko keine
empfehlung auszusprechen für kinder aber
die eine chronische erkrankung schon
haben da ist sie aus christi
ausgesprochen aber ist es eine
derzeitigen empfehlung die sich in der
zukunft aber auch ändern kann auch das
finde ich wichtig hervorzuheben dass sie
derzeit eben das nicht empfehlen und ich
finde er lauter war dass das ein wenig
doch zur spaltung der gesellschaft die
wir haben die sie da machen diese stieg
so zu attackieren beitrag gesenkt und
schließlich kurz an das ich mich doch
mal kurz aus werden also ich finde es
auch eigentlich höchst unanständig wie
sie mir zum beispiel in interviews
unterstellen dass ich den lockdown
überflüssig finde ich habe drei mal vier
mal gesagt dass sie den alt-rocker und
sogar alternativlos finde
damit tragen sie aber einmal auf der zur
spaltung bei und ich finde das hat so
ein wahlkampf stil der einfach für eine
pandemie nicht angebracht ist da sind
leute die sich um ihre existenz sorgen
machen und ich bin nicht im wahlkampf
ich möchte pragmatische
lösungsvorschläge machen und das machen
sie nicht das erste mal sie haben ja
nach der letzten in einer sendung wo ich
war gesagt ich würde ich sagte man darf
nicht nur auf die menge ins tendenzen
sondern auch auf die augen musste auch
auf die hospitalisierung traten schauen
und sieht wieder raus ich finde es
vollkommen falsch nur auf die
hospitalisierung raten zu schauen oder
so wie sie mich mal passieren aber was
ich damit sagen will
ich finde solche angriffe und sich nicht
richtig zuzuhören auch was herr laumann
ja gesagt hab vorhin er macht ja sehr
genaue tests immer in nrw er möchte ja
die incident so weit runter halten und
wenn es nicht geht dann geht es nicht
dann gibt es wieder auch härtere
maßnahmen aber das sind ja
differenzierte aussagen und sie machen
dann solche brutalen nach aussagen
daraus zu lassen du hast mich trotzdem
reagieren zunächst zunächst mal zuhören
laumann
ich habe bei einer man darauf
hingewiesen dass du selbst man als ich
das falsche signal ist das jetzt zu
eröffnen
und ich glaube wir verstehen uns gut
genug als dass es da keinen dissens gibt
unseren fachlicher punkt und es wird
sich zeigen durchführen ich bin froh
wenn es anders ist also wenn tatsächlich
die impfquote jetzt wieder anspringen
sollte also meine sorge ist dass durch
das signal was jetzt gesetzt wurde die
impfquote zurückgeht dann lag ich falsch
liegen sehen sehen wir jetzt zu ihnen es
ging jetzt gerade wirklich nicht um sie
es ging also um die stiko und ich habe
nicht die stiko angegriffen sondern ich
habe wissenschaftlich versucht
herzuleiten dass ich mit dem inhalt der
entscheidung nichts zufrieden bin und
das ist keine majestätsbeleidigung das
ist keine die stiko geht sehr
transparent mit der argumentation um und
finde ich großartig und also ich also
reagiere darauf rein inhaltlich ich
finde die stiko macht gute arbeit
hier habe vor zwei tagen oder wochen
habe ich zum beispiel noch also gelobt
dass die stiko eine klare empfehlung für
die also bei tag oder moderner impfungen
die courts impfung gegeben hat uns so
somit wo mir etwas bei der stiko gefällt
da lobe ich das und wo es mir nicht
gefällt kritisiere ich in der sache und
soll ich sagen so nah ist auch mit ihnen
ich habe bei entlastungsstraße
belastungen geschlossen wie das geht
sie haben sich jetzt auf geworfen in dem
sie also zum beispiel also ich bin also
tatsächlich der mahnung dass sie den ein
oder anderen lockdown denen wir dringend
benötigt hätten entweder nicht gefordert
haben wo hätte gefordert werden müssen
oder sogar abgelehnt haben das ist
damals also zu sagen war ich anderer
meinung
aber dort wo sie recht gehabt haben da
gebe ich ihnen recht ich hatte zum
beispiel unlängst gelobt dass sie die
saisonalität also von saas kauf relativ
früh erkannt hatten das ist also da
bricht mir kein zacken aus der krone und
ich daher also versuche ich wenigstens
mit dem was ich tue sehr sehr eng am
inhalt zu segeln und nie zu spalten ich
werde nie persönlich habe zum beispiel
zu ihnen noch nie außer in der sache
eine persönliche also kritik vorgetragen
das mache ich grundsätzlich und damit
habe ja oft genug gesagt dass ich den
locker und richtig und wichtig fand aber
sagen dass man ja ist ein gesagt habe er
wäre überflüssig ja ich weiß also dass
lassen lassen es ist einfach da stehen
also ich bin manchmal der meinung
gewesen dass der look down von ihnen
hätte begleitet werden müssen wo sie ihn
abgelehnt haben ich stehe nicht allein
damit dieser position und aber das ist
kann also persönlicher punkt sondern
also ich hätte ihr qualifikation und
arbeit ich bin aber der meinung dass
also der lock down zu einem zeitpunkt
wurden beispielsweise beispielsweise
leute wie viola briesemann oder melanie
brinkmann michael hermann
christian drosten und ich wo wir den
gefordert haben da hätten wir uns
gefolgt wenn sie sich angeschlossen
hätten sie haben es habe damals nicht
getan und das ist einfach nichts anderes
als ein fachlicher disput gar nichts